the poet roland barthes talks about the
amorous embrace as this post-coital
cuddling this inter subjective ecstasy
that you enter with your romantic
partner and that is that is beyond
sexuality that is beyond physical
attraction that space of shared soul
smearing sort of sexually enabled
technologically mediated Buddhist space
where to become one I keep bringing back
the term intersubjective ecstasy why we
love to call it a while we'd love to
give each other baby names and and treat
each other like your little children and
create kind of more like spaces of
comfort and divinity for one another we
can be as gods outside of time
temporarily stepping off that people
mover that's carrying everyone else
towards death as Alan Harrington says
you know we're trying to find escapes
from the despair together we're creating
a shared universe where we can float
above the clouds of Mentor
not die look that is what love is about
it's about saving ourselves from
mortality you know we are the gods with
anuses as Ernest Becker says and we do
everything we can to deny our own
creatureliness too to deny our own decay
despair can you blame us for squeezing
so tightly around one another can you
blame us for wanting to listen to
beautiful music and cry together can you
blame us for wanting to seek out comfort
in each other's core soul space and to
say please tell me you not leave me you
will not disappear I will not be alone
you know I'm not gonna drown you know
just like you know that's what we want
that's what we seek and they say oh
we're codependent we're weak we should
be independent come on man it's what all
the psychedelic explorers have told us
it's eco Dalek it's all interconnected
we are all one we're not alone it's okay
to be codependent it's not a bad thing
you